qualsiasi cosa farete dopo il thè tex
probabilmente avrà a che fare con un
foglio bianco un foglio bianco e il
principio di molte cose e padre di
grande ansia ed è padre di grande
eccitazione
in entrambi i casi perché contiene
infinite possibilità questo penso oggi e
questo pensavo anche nel 2008 quando
davanti un foglio bianco come questo ho
iniziato il mio percorso professionale
utilizziamo un foglio bianco per poter
tracciare un piano ci serve un piano per
cercare di ottenere successo in quello
che ci accingiamo a fare
esistono tante definizioni di successo
eppure nella pratica se avete avuto a
che fare come me con un foglio bianco
probabilmente vi siete allineati alla
definizione più semplice successo uguale
evitare il fallimento
il fallimento è considerato l'antitesi
del successo se iniziamo a tracciare il
nostro piano ci troviamo probabilmente a
partire dalle regole acquisite
una delle regole più note nonché la mia
preferita è conoscenza è potere
la conoscenza come elemento determinante
per il successo sapere più degli altri è
il motivo per cui nostra madre ci
insegue per casa da bambini
costringendoci a leggere più libri è
anche il motivo per cui nostro padre si
decide a dare fondo ai risparmi di
famiglia per finanziare 18 anni di studi
che ci separano dall ingresso nel mondo
del lavoro
la conoscenza come vantaggio competitivo
c'è un altro modo di guardare alla
conoscenza però ed è conoscenza uguale
rendita
questo è un concetto che viene
soprattutto dal mondo dei nostri padri
studiavo ingegneria probabilmente
concluderò la mia vita lavorando da
ingegnere conoscenza come rendita
significa accumulare una grande massa di
conoscenza che poi utilizzo nel tempo al
costo di qualche minimo aggiornamento
quello che ho studiato probabilmente mi
basterà per tutta la vita
e questo quindi rende assolutamente
sensato spendere soldi e tempo per
cercare di acquisire questa massa di
conoscenza anche io nel 2008 all'inizio
del mio percorso ero profondamente
convinto di questa verità come si
costruisce come si genera questa
conoscenza la conoscenza può essere
creata a partire da conoscenza che già
esiste oppure acquisendo delle
informazioni diciamo semplificando che è
più informazioni uguale più conoscenza
più conoscenza uguale più successo di
conseguenza più informazioni uguale più
successo e se ci pensate questa
associazione è abbastanza consolidata
l'uomo di successo e identificato spesso
con colui che sa l'uomo in formato
contrapposta l'uomo ignorante che è
carente di conoscenza informazione e
proprio per questo è condannato a subire
il proprio destino
questo clichè e alla base della
persecuzione che la mia generazione ha
subito spesso al liceo eravamo colpevoli
di non leggere abbastanza quotidiani
perché il quotidiano era il veicolo
dell'informazione
effettivamente nel mondo in cui poi noi
siamo diventati adulti
il quotidiano non è più la fonte
principale di informazione
l'informazione ormai è ovunque intorno a
noi grazie a internet l'informazione in
tasca nel mio smartphone e nel mio
orologio e nei miei occhiali tutta
questa informazione ha cambiato
radicalmente il contesto all'interno del
quale ci muoviamo
se io cerco su internet come costruire
una bomba atomica
ottengo più di due milioni e mezzo di
risultati in meno di un secondo prima di
internet non ci ponevamo il problema
della capacità di elaborazione delle
informazioni con internet è evidente che
la mole di informazioni a cui abbiamo
accesso ci pone anche un problema di
elaborazione
se volessi appunto esplorare questo tema
assimilando i due milioni e mezzo di
risultati che mi vengono offerti su
internet
probabilmente non mi basterebbe il tempo
farei prima ultimare un corso di studi
nell'epoca di internet
il tempo non è più misurato i minuti
ma in numero di email che si accumulano
nella nostra inbox questo genere un
nuovo tipo di ignoranza un ignorante che
non è ignorante perché non ha accesso
alle informazioni ma è ignorante perché
così tanto bombardato di informazioni
che non ha tempo per generare conoscenza
non ha tempo per elaborarle quindi più
informazione uguale più saturazione
uguale meno conoscenza quello che si è
realizzato nel periodo di internet è una
maggiore complessità nella generazione
della conoscenza
effettivamente però la brutta notizia è
che anche la conoscenza che riesco a
generare o che oggi ha generato non vale
più tanto questo per favore non ditelo
ai nostri padri che si sono indebitati
per farci studiare non vale più tanto
perché con internet succedono due cose
la prima che l'informazione la
conoscenza diventano abbondanti e hino
segue il principio di scarsità perdono
valore quello che ormai so è qualcosa
che presto saprete anche voi le vostre
idee più innovative si trovano già su
internet da qualche parte
persino i segreti di stato non sono più
tanto segreti la seconda cosa che è
successa con internet è che
l'informazione diventa presto obsoleta
tutta questa accelerazione nella
combinazione della conoscenza genera
nuova conoscenza in continuazione quindi
quello che so presto diventerà
tendenzialmente inutile se la conoscenza
non è più un vantaggio competitivo a
cosa dobbiamo guardare per cercare di
avere successo nel mondo di oggi
permettetemi di raccontarvi una storia
questa storia è una metafora inventata
da russell e ripresa da popper e parla
di un tacchino il tacchino della storia
riceve da mangiare dall'essere umano 12
37 giorni
all'ottavo giorno si arrischia a fare
una previsione
ed effettivamente ha successo
l'essere umano anche l'ottavo giorno
ritorno alla stessa ora e lo nutre
l'essere umano sfama il tacchino per 364
giorni permettendo al tacchino quindi di
accumulare conoscenza
e soprattutto di fare delle previsioni
accurate sul futuro tutto questo è
valido fino al 300 65 esimo giorno il
365 esimo giorno è il giorno del
ringraziamento il giorno in cui il
tacchino finisce nel forno un solo
giorno cambia la prospettiva di 364
giorni di osservazione costante omogenea
un solo fallimento ridefinisce una
realtà consolidata in 364 giorni di
conoscenza accumulata questo scenario
non è più l'eccezione è la regola del
mondo in cui viviamo
come fare quindi ad avere successo in
questo mondo
la risposta che ho trovato nel mio
percorso è data da un aspirapolvere uno
di quegli affari tondeggianti che molti
di voi hanno a casa e che promettono
pulizia totale con fatica 0
se ci pensate questo apparecchio a due
peculiarità la prima che ovviamente nel
momento in cui viene imballato non sa a
quale casa è destinato quindi non può
essere precostruito in funzione
dell'ambiente in cui si muoverà la
seconda caratteristica di questo
apparecchio è che anche quando lo
mettete in funzione non può puntare
sulla conoscenza che acquisisce dello
scenario in cui si muove sulla
conoscenza che ha della vostra stanza
perché la stanza cambia ogni giorno la
serie un po più spostata lo zaino è sul
tappeto le scarpe sono all'ingresso
questo è particolarmente vero casa mia
quindi questo apparecchio si troverà a
muoversi in un ambiente sempre diverso
per cui è poco sensato basare la
strategia sulla conoscenza accumulata
per avere successo questo apparecchio
deve puntare su una metodologia di
apprendimento che è una metodologia che
gli permette di adattarsi allo scenario
in cui si muove dove appunto sfrutta
l'unica costante certa che è il
cambiamento questo scenario cambia
sempre la domanda a questo punto diventa
è possibile costruire una simile ricetta
e incorporarle in una strategia
utilizzata da esseri umani per
raggiungere il successo
il mio percorso mi ha insegnato che si
e possibile e in particolare nel modello
che vi propongo gli ingredienti
principali sono tre il primo ingrediente
è ricerca continua continuare a testare
la variazione è a cercare anche quando
abbiamo raggiunto il successo
supponiamo che io vi mostri due carte
una al dorso rosso e l'altra a il dorso
blu supponiamo che io vi chieda di
cercare il numero pari che si cela
dietro una delle due carte dicendovi che
dietro la carta col dorso rosso
normalmente c'è sempre un numero pari
mentre dietro la carta con il dorso blu
normalmente c'è sempre un numero dispari
probabilmente molti di voi come feci io
la prima volta che mi posero il quesito
volteranno immediatamente la carta rossa
a questo punto se dietro la carta rossa
si cela davvero un numero pari
questo ci sa ci darà soddisfazione
perché perché siamo abituati a pensare
così cercare conferme alle nostre
ipotesi
eppure dovremmo anche voltare la carta
blu perché se dietro la carta blu ci
fosse pure un numero pari
qualcosa è andato storto non voltare la
carta blu significa candidarsi a fare la
fine del tacchino questa ricerca
continua è però molto onerosa una
ricerca molto onerosa significa
dispendio di energia effettivamente il
secondo ingrediente tende a risolvere
questo problema il secondo ingrediente
la condivisione e la possibilità di
mettersi in contatto all'interno di un
network con altre persone
condividendo risorse questo aumenta le
mie capacità di rispondere allo scenario
e soprattutto di utilizzare le risorse
per elaborare per esempio l'enorme mole
di informazione che a cui sono
sottoposto la vostra prossima posizione
lavorativa probabilmente arriverà da uno
dei vostri contatti come si possono
costruire network di relazioni tra
persone
esiste un ingrediente fondamentale che è
la fiducia negli altri
la fiducia serve a generare relazione
diffidate di chi vi dice che la fiducia
arriva dopo la relazione come una forma
di premio di verifica della lazio
se stessa la fiducia precede la
relazione senza fiducia non posso creare
relazione questo potere del network
viene catturato da un modo di dire che
viene attribuito al popolo africano
se vuoi andare veloce vai solo ma se
vuoi andare lontano vai in compagnia
il terzo ingrediente è il fallimento e
non potrei descriverlo se non con le
parole di michael jordan che vedete alle
mie spalle
all'inizio del mio discorso vi ho
parlato del fallimento come antitesi del
successo
adesso sto cercando di inserirlo come
ingrediente principale dentro una
metodologia che vi porta al successo
come mai effettivamente il fallimento se
smettessimo di temerlo c mostrerebbe che
l'esperienza che sta dietro al
fallimento ha un grande valore perché
uno dei modi migliori per processare le
informazioni che ci portano alla
conoscenza più fallimento uguale più
esperienza più esperienza uguale più
conoscenza più conoscenza uguale più
successo il fallimento si è accelerato
può essere un fattore di successo più
fallimento uguale più successo questi
tre ingredienti che ho sperimentato
sulla mia pelle
li ho ritrovati molto tempo dopo aver
elaborato queste considerazioni in un
libro che stava sulla mia nella mia
libreria ma che non avevo mai letto
questo libro pensato è stato pubblicato
nel 1859 ad opera di charles darwin
darwin in questo libro spiega proprio
come gli esseri viventi si aggregano
beneficiano delle diversità e falliscono
il tutto proprio per cercare di
sopravvivere
ebbene se avessi letto questo libro e le
sue conclusioni prima di aver vissuto
quello che ho vissuto
effettivamente questo mi avrebbe
permesso di soffrire di meno
la risposta è no perché esiste un quarto
ingrediente fondamentale in qualsiasi
modello ed è il tempo siamo abituati a
pensare al tempo come kronos uno
scorrere omogeneo che in qualche modo
cerchiamo di non sprecare proprio perché
non
possiamo conservare eppure il tempo e
anche kairos e opportunità è il momento
giusto
ebbene la parola chiave di questo
ingrediente e perseveranza proprio
perché anni di spreco possono essere
riscattati da pochi momenti all'interno
della giusta finestra di opportunità
la mia esperienza mi ha insegnato che
costruire le condizioni affinché possa
avvenire una finestra di opportunità
significa spesso sprecare tanto tempo
vi ho detto finora che nella mia
esperienza operare una ricerca continua
condividere e avere fiducia e
perseverare vi porteranno a fallire
spesso e che da questo fallire
fallimento voi potete estrarre della
conoscenza che vi serve per arrivare al
successo però non sono stato
completamente onesto con voi
del resto chiunque abbia sperimentato il
fallimento sa che esistono fallimenti da
cui possiamo trarre insegnamento e
fallimenti che ci uccidono che non
ammettono il secondo tempo qual è la
differenza fra le due cose vorrei
ritornare al concetto di network tra
persona e il network tra persone non è
soltanto un modo per condividere e
ottenere risorse e anche una rete di
salvataggio
nella mia esperienza la differenza tra i
fallimenti che schiacciano e i
fallimenti che sono esperienza l'hanno
fatta proprio le persone nel 2008 ero
convinto che avrei riempito il mio
foglio bianco con modelli eleganti e
teorie interessanti sul successo nella
pratica questo foglio se lo guardo oggi
è pieno di parole di gratitudine
gratitudine verso le persone che mi
hanno aiutato in questi anni verso il
mio network di relazione tutte le volte
che ha avuto successo è stato perché
avevo sbagliato strada oppure avevo
completamente sbagliato i calcoli il
motivo per cui da questi fallimenti sono
riuscito a generare successo è stato
grazie al mio network di conoscenze che
ho imparato a strutturare ai tempi
dell'università in un ambiente che era
disegnato appositamente per assimilare
struire dei network grazie alle persone
del mio network che mi hanno aiutato
questo fallimento non mi ha schiacciato
quindi la mia conclusione è che in un
mondo dove abbonda il fallimento
l'unico modo per avere successo e
affrontarlo con abbondanza di relazioni
e vuol dire abbondanza di fiducia negli
altri
la buona notizia che la fiducia negli
altri come risorsa condivide con
l'ignoto una caratteristica importante è
inesauribile
grazie